[Music]
[Applause]
Hey hi Jeffrey hi don't worry we're
doing good everybody's excited thank you
so much for coming all the way up from
LA we appreciate the visit and excited
to be here we're very excited to have
you that was an incredible list of
accomplishments and you started off
without getting a degree can you tell us
why I will but I you know I actually
I've always found in speaking in front
of any groups it's actually valuable for
me to know a little bit about the
audience and so if I could just do a
really quick survey of how many foams
are there here that are headed to Vegas
tonight could I see a show of hands oh
boy
so I would just want to give you sort of
two things that I I might be able to
help you out on the first is likely
probably not a lot of people in this
room that could give you wardrobe advice
as to how to dress for the 1970s I
actually can do that I have knowledge
and experience there and probably more
importantly than that you should know
that right around the corner from the
Marquee Club at the Cosmopolitan is the
best pizza in Las Vegas
it's called secret pizza it is a secret
but now there are a couple of hundred of
you that know the secret it's open till
5:00 a.m. which is I'm sure right around
the time in which you'll be wanting and
Jones and on some pizza so I did not go
to college
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
interesting thing that I partnered in
1994 with Steven Spielberg and David
Geffen the three of us do actually do
not have a college degree so of whatever
that's worth I didn't go to college cuz
I actually started working very young as
a teenager I volunteered for a man who
ran for mayor of New York City John
Lindsay who had been a congressman on
the Upper East Side and Lindsay was
really an incredibly charismatic very
forward-thinking very I think engaging
and thoughtful unique liberal politician
and came at a time in an era where
participating and giving and being
involved and civic you know was pretty
powerful you know the late 60s was you
know a time of a lot of civil rights
movements really you know changing
moments in our culture and our society
and being there in politics in
government was a very exciting thing and
I started very young as a teenager and
continued to work and when that moment I
actually I did go to college for a
moment I registered at NYU because it
was the closest College to City Hall and
in that era you actually only had to
hand your class card in and then show up
for exams so it was a pretty easy for me
to go to college
and the I think the first in 1970 the
first midterm exam overlapped with the
first police strike in a modern city in
America the police went on strike in New
York State
which had never happened before and I
thought I could do better there than in
a college classroom and that was the end
of my college career what did you learn
from those years that you've taken into
your career later Oh everything I mean
it was just it was a less were lessons
in life and and about people and you
know values and seen the harsh realities
of the streets of New York and the goods
the bads and the Uglies and honestly
there's not in those five or six seven
years that I worked for the mayor I
actually saw everything I was a advance
man for the mayor and who loved to be on
the streets of New York felt that he
should be there whenever wherever
anything exceptional or extraordinary
was happening and it required the
resources of government to be there and
respond so every time at anytime
anything bad happened he wanted to show
up and make sure that government was
there doing its job so whether it's a
tenement would burn down or subway
accident or a police officer shot in the
line of duty or you know a water main
break or anything that was at all
disruptive he felt as the leader of the
city he should be there front and center
to see that the city did its its job and
so for me as an advanced man
it pretty much put me in the wrong place
at the wrong time pretty much every
every day and so you learn about amazing
amazing things about life and death and
and you know moments of you know
happiness and sacrifice and just
everything it's just the entire rainbow
of colors of you know everything around
life were reflected in those experiences
and I think they you know just served me
very well and they matured me in a way
and they gave me a confidence about
myself I think which was you know unique
and and for somebody so young I had
these life experiences at an extremely
early age and a sense of responsibility
as a leader
yeah you can make a difference you know
this idea that you know you you can't
change the course of things I don't I
don't buy that about anything but
particularly you know I think that and
even today I think about it people feel
like well if you don't like something
what do you do about it and I would say
well you have two things and and they
are invaluable and I think we tend not
to understand how important and how
valuable they are it's your voice and
your vote and so right now today you
know we're sort of going sideways here
you know for for me and politics today I
don't think there's ever been a more
important time in which we have to
exercise our voice in our vote and we
have elections that are coming up later
this year we have elections that are
coming up and you know a little more
than two and a half years and for me in
terms of what I'm more focused on than
anything else today is I would love to
see this next election cycle these next
two election cycles particularly 2020 I
would like to see a participation in a
turnout in our democracy the likes of
which our country has never experienced
before because the stakes have never
been higher and so up for this audience
in particular you know there's nothing
more important than voter registration
and voter participation it is the
foundation of our democracy and it is a
choice it is a moment in time in which
we actually get to determine the course
of our country and our leaders and we
only have ourselves to thank or blame
for you know where we are go vote
[Applause]
so that call to foster expression and to
hear voices is that what brought you
into Hollywood no I wanted no I was 22
years old and so Lindsay ran for
president in 1972 I worked in Wisconsin
in Florida which were the two primaries
when he lost in those primaries and you
know went back to city government I did
not want to go back to city government
cuz I felt like I had done everything
that I could do and I wanted some I
wanted a new challenge at 22 years old I
really had sort of risen as far as I was
practical in you know government I don't
think I was gonna get made police
commissioner or fire commissioner and so
I wanted to go find a career in an
industry where at least age would not
hold me back and many people said go
look at entertainment look at the movie
business because it is a place in which
you know youth is actually a valued
asset not a liability and so that that
is actually sort of the the big idea of
why and you know I got a couple little
opportunities but then I had the really
great fortune of meeting this amazing
amazing person Barry Diller who invented
something called movies of the week
which we don't have anymore on TV but it
was a really both creative and an
entrepreneur and he had just been made
the chairman of Paramount Pictures at
the age of 34 years old just rather
extraordinary and Barry hi Ernie
as his gofer and you know which I think
I went to work when I was 23 and and
then over the course of the next 11
years that I worked at Paramount and I
worked for Barry
he did one of the most amazing things
which is
he really genuinely mentored me he
invested in me he believed in me and he
in a in a very really sort of almost
thoughtful methodical way I didn't
understand it at the time but he had me
work in every area of the company and so
by the time I was 29 years old so I
worked for six years I was in marketing
and distribution and international and
negative pickups and TV and I had all
these experiences where I would work for
a year or so in one of these and then
he'd move me into something else and I
wasn't I didn't see any grand plan here
in this I guess I just was getting moved
or out of debt but you know when I was
29 years old there he usually made me
president of the studio and I actually
could do the job and the only reason I
could do the job is that because he had
taken the time to actually train me and
give me the resources to to function in
the job can you tell us a little bit
about a day in the life as the head of a
studio well yeah I mean I'll focus just
maybe narrowly on movies because they're
there you know that was what I was doing
at Paramount when I went to Disney it
was sort of a broader job because it
involved you know television and
animation and much wider
responsibilities but at Paramount and
running a studio really is about finding
great ideas and finding great talent
creating a great environment for people
to be able to pursue and realize dreams
even though those dreams in many cases
are anywhere between improbable and
impossible and to create an environment
where people have the the ability to
fail and to take risk and reason for
that is is that great stories great
movie telling is at its best when its
original and unique and if you sort of
think of
it almost as a mathematical equation
original and unique equals risky right
so no it's not a proven formula and
risky equals at least to some degree
failure so if you don't allow some
failure in the equation you're not gonna
have people do things that are risky and
unique and if you know I'm a better
unique and original if you don't have
unique and original everything becomes a
derivative and I think uninspired and
you won't have success so creating a
great environment for people to take
that appropriate amount of risk and to
actually be able to have the ambition to
do things that sometimes aren't going to
work now very specifically you know I I
don't maybe it came from those years and
I have a insane work ethic and and habit
and I I get up very early in the morning
I have done people may have heard I have
multiple breakfast is multiple lunches
multiple dinners and how about that so
that's genetic thank my parents for that
I sleep five hours a night I thank my
parents for that I don't get jetlag I
thank my parents for that this is all in
the gene pool I have nothing to do with
it but just if you only sleep five hours
a night which I have done since I was
fifteen years old that beetles actually
wrote a song for me it's called eight
days a week that was for me anyway so I
got an extra day and I might I'm I
invest my time and the reason people you
know nobody's ever actually asked me so
why do you have all these breakfast
lunches and dinner I'm going to tell you
including some of my partners who were
sitting here in front of me I have found
as a head of a studio there's a there's
a very great distance between you and a
talent and artists and again there's a
there's a little bit of fear and you
know as you grow both in the job that
you have but
so reputationally and they create
mythology around you and you know coming
to see me over the years it started to
get to the point where it's like going
to see Oz it scares you to death and I
found that the way to like take that out
of the equation was across a table with
a meal and that suddenly the just the
the the the relaxed nature of sitting at
a table with somebody coming and
bringing you know food and eating just
made it gave me an ability to connect
with people way way way better than I
could
across a desk in an office or sitting
you know on the other side of a couch
and so I just found that I'm way more
productive mind so I would get up and I
would have breakfast at 6 7 8 in the
morning all three of those by the way
and so you know in a studio you know a
typical Monday morning we would of the
first thing we would do is have a
weekend read so probably maybe the most
important valuable thing as an executive
that you have to do is read and I think
that all great movies start with a great
idea all great ideas must have a great
story and so reading is essential and I
will tell you just how demanding it was
is a typical week for me when I was at
Paramount is I would actually read 10 or
12 screenplays a week and I'm not a
super fast reader I am dyslexic and so I
actually have to read a little slow and
so it would take me almost you know it'd
take me almost two hours to read a
screenplay and I used to actually come
start at 6 o'clock on Saturday mornings
and read till 5:00 6 o'clock in the
afternoon and then come back and
probably do about half of that on us on
a Sunday for years I mean years and
years and years I have read thousands of
screenplays literally and so then on
Monday morning we all would come in and
we would actually
talk about what we read and what were
the good ideas and who were the great
writers and and then you'd move through
the day and there would be things about
meeting with filmmakers and hearing what
their take on their story was why they
wanted to do it and then you know kind
of through the process of a movie of
everything from the you know assembling
the team of around it the producers the
directors the the cast you know pretty
much every element of it where was it
going to be done the budget the
marketing so these are all elements of
moviemaking and and they're still you
know kind of relevant today and it's
probably organized a little bit
differently today but certainly back
then that was what a what a day was for
me and you know we had had previews of
our movies we always found a great
collaboration with our audience when we
have a movie that was a work in progress
being having that moment where a
filmmaker or a storyteller could
actually hear an audience in that sort
of just natural involuntary response to
a film and to see you know was it going
too fast was it going too slow was it
confusing that's just you know just
sitting in the back of an audience it's
not about sort of testing it's not about
sort of filling out preview cards which
I'm sure everybody has done that's tough
kind of nonsense but just sitting in an
audience you can tell so much about
things that are working and things that
are not working you've described your
work ethic and giving all Saturday part
of Sunday making work your life have you
seen that have a really strong impact on
the teams around you how is that evolved
for you well it's a fortunately it's
evolved because I started off sort of I
guess a Neanderthal because I actually
once said a number of years ago if you
don't come to work on Saturday don't
bother coming on Sunday now
now here's the problem with that when I
said it I meant it and you know the
lessons that you that I learned I think
anybody learns is is that you learn that
working smarter sometimes has as much
value as working harder and you also
learn that having you know what is sort
of popularly referred to as sort of
work-life balance is not just a nice
theoretical thought I think it's
actually true and so I can kid all I
want about it but the fact is I have a
wonderful family I have you know you
know been married for forty five years
to an amazing amazing partner have two
kids three grandkids you know very proud
of how my kids grew up and how they
became people and found their own
identity and their own careers and and
that's you know that became as an
important part of it and so you know in
my 20s that was probably fine is
probably fine for all of you but there's
a moment in time in which you actually
have to find those things that make you
whole as a human being and then make you
better at what you're doing and so
having that that element as an important
part of your life is I think an
invaluable asset of doing a great job
that's the boss respecting that in your
team and the team around you and what
you're building have to yeah so if we
move into the Disney years everyone has
a favorite child so do you have a
favorite film from that time there are
different movies that have you know
different so first of all the other
genetic defect I have in addition to
those others that I gave you is is that
I I don't have a a reminiscent gene and
and so I tend not to look back and most
of all when something's finished for me
it's I turn the chapter and I go to the
next thing and so I've least to date
I've not yet found that moment to turn
back and actually be reflective in a way
about it but there are things and
stories that I have told over the years
that had a connection to me because I
had something to do with the idea itself
and the idea was in some way a
reflection of something going on for me
I say that and I want to wave the flag
of saying I had some peace in that
because I don't want to take credit from
great writers great directors great
filmmakers whose names are on these
things it's just you know there was this
Sam Goldwyn who's one of the great
producers in early Hollywood had an
expression which I love
which he said you know credit you give
yourself isn't worth having and so I I
say that as a caveat here of the story
of the Lion King is a reflection of
something that happened to me in my life
in my 20s and I wanted to tell that in a
story not the hamlet part that I had
nothing to do with there's a guy Willie
shake something or other he was that but
the the notion that for those of you who
may have a minor memory of this is is
that Simba believes that he was
responsible for the death of his dad and
he runs because he does not feel he can
confront that truth to his mom and to
his family and to his tribe and so he
goes away and finds Pumbaa and Timon and
Hakuna Matata
and eventually Nala shows up this
childhood friend of his and reminds him
of what's there and then between Rafiki
shaking his magic wand and Mufasa from
up there you must return he goes back
and faces his truth and I had a
situation in my life in my career in
which that happened to me not in the
familial way which I felt would be the
way in which we could all relate to it
but there was a set of circumstances in
which everything was on the line for me
and it was a chance for me to cut and
run and and I knew ultimately someday I
you cannot run from the truth the truth
will find you and so I made a very bold
and very hard and very difficult
decision for me to come back and face
the truth and by the way the outcome was
great you know for for me in doing that
and I just felt that was such a life
learning lesson for me that I wanted to
try and tell that in a story there's
another movie I've made which probably
many of you don't never know or maybe
bark barely heard about which was also a
reflection of something from me which is
about how I feel about life I actually
don't like the word no maybe some of you
do but it doesn't work for me and pretty
much any any you know I and so there was
a movie called spirit stallion of the
Cimarron and it's a it was the last
hand-drawn animated movie that I made as
that sort of revolution of CG came along
Shrek was the next one after it and it
was a very very it was my homage to you
know really one of the great things that
I I think Walt Disney did
which was it it's to allow animation to
to be it's it's it's best and and to let
the pictures do all the storytelling so
the lead character which is this
indomitable character spirit he he
doesn't talk right so there's it it
relies on animation to actually tell
itself and it's a musical
and it nobody sings other than Bryan
Adams who sings this sort of you know
kind of soundtrack to it so it was a
really incredibly ambitious very risky
animated movie that failed but but not
for me and that story specifically of
spirit which is he is a character that
no matter what the circumstances his
optimism and his determination would not
allow him to fail and that's that's me
I I'm I'm I just you know I have you
know just a bottomless well of optimism
and so and then the third one is I grew
up across from the New York City Central
Park Zoo and I used to go there as a
young kid 5 6 7 8 years old and it
always when I would see the zoo through
the you know my eyes is that you know as
a kid I thought well they live on Fifth
Avenue I'd see they got fed steak every
day they were groomed and taken care of
and their cages will all be washed and
cleaned every day and I thought god
these animals like they're they like
they're living the top of the mind I
thought well what would happen if they
had to actually go back to Africa and
there is Madagascar it sounds like this
incredibly personal connection for you
in making these films it's the one the
ones that really stick with you
the animated ones for sure but they're
great movies over the years that are
just you know wonderful things where
great filmmakers great storytellers
great artists you know had these amazing
stories they wanted to tell and
to kind of be on the sidelines
cheerleading them helping them realize
those things was just very exciting but
you know I I made 406 live-action movies
when I say I made they were made while I
was you know overseeing these studios
over the years and 41 animated movies
and you know was a lot and man there are
just a ton of dogs in there you had an
abrupt departure from Disney can you
talk to us about what that was like sure
so in the summer of 1994 the number one
movie in the world was the Lion King the
number one album soundtrack or actually
record period was a soundtrack to Lion
King sold twenty seven twenty eight
million hard copies anybody want to
think about that today with that with
that light but that's how extraordinary
that is the number one home video in the
world was from Aladdin the year before
the number one show on Broadway was
Beauty and the Beast number one TV show
was a show we produced called home
improvement the number one book on the
New York Times best you get the idea
like in a moment in time and I don't
know whether that's happened again since
or not maybe it has certainly possible
for the Disney Company today we had
number one of every single place that we
produced for which is pretty much across
the entire spectrum of things that are
around entertainment and culture I got
fired and and it was horribly ugly I
mean it was a it was a you know I had
had been together with
CEO of the company and Michael Eisner
knives and partners together for 18 and
a half years and I guess the analogy I
would make except I'm fortunate and I
have not experienced this but I have
friends that have it's like a marriage
that went perfectly to a point and then
somehow or another just got unaligned
and there's a reason for this is is that
Michael and I had this amazing marriage
counselor who is the president of the
company amazing guy selfless one of the
most selfless people I've ever met his
name is Frank Wells and so there was
Michael as the CEO the company and Frank
was the CEO oh and I was the CEO of the
of the Walt Disney Studios and Frank for
all of these years 10 10 years he was
the guy that always kind of made things
right between Michael and I and that
when we would sort of get unaligned or
at each other or I wasn't being
sensitive or not for not being inclusive
or whatever those things are Frank would
come in my office sit down and put his
feet up on the table and go I think
there's a better way of doing this and
he managed to do that and then quite
tragically in April of 1994 he died in a
helicopter crash you know this is where
you know my my partner one of my partner
has always said to me Jeffrey you know
there's your plan and there's God's plan
- your plan doesn't count and this is
one of those moments where suddenly
everything that worked nothing worked
and and so Michael and I got sideways
with one another very quickly and and
and in a way that became just amazing
eruption and and he fired me and at the
moment in time in which I was doing my
job as well as I'd ever done it before
and and at the time it was incredibly
public and incredibly ugly and very
personal and very nasty and it resulted
in a lawsuit and you know just went on
for a really long time and I would have
to rank that as probably my greatest
regret professionally not that I got
fired it's how I got fired I may not
make any sense to you but
the I just look back today and I'm there
must have been a better way for me to go
about separating and and and I if I
could have a do-over at least I would
try and do that and I don't know they
would have a different outcome I don't
think it would but it would have had a
better way to get to the outcome of it
because it's the most humiliating
embarrassing moment of my of my career I
felt just completely you know the mean
to buy it and and you know just hurt by
it and it just it was it was hard eight
days later after getting fired I started
DreamWorks with Gavin Stephenson so I
got over it in about seven and a half
days yes but I just hear so much love
for the films and the people involved at
Disney and just I really appreciate that
you shared all of that with us and but
you did you turned right around and took
an entrepreneurial leap when you could
have taken an operating role at any of
the established studios with the track
record I mean you just made number one
and every measure so why take the leap
um
well again I you know the sort of
recurring thing for me and literally
going back to those days of Lindsay and
Paramount and Disney and DreamWorks and
again here today now I have I have loved
the idea of a blank slate I know for
most people you know that's a scary it's
a scary thing particularly you know most
of these are almost almost like
clockwork you know these have been ten
years in my career and so they're long
and they're deep roots and it's attached
to people and projects and friends and
family and that I grew up with in each
of these chapters but I find that for
for me whether it's the circumstances
change the team broke up or I got fired
starting over has always been fantastic
for me and what has come in front of me
has always every single time no matter
how great the circumstances so as great
as paramount was for me or Disney with
me and they were fantastic times and
incredible decades there and so much to
love and be proud of what came next was
better and so when Comcast showed up a
year and a half ago I thought I would my
third act was gonna be doing you know
another 10 years of DreamWorks
and making number 407 and 42 and and at
first it was like well what do you mean
you want my company you don't want me
hurt by that for a moment and then I
thought about it and honestly one day I
woke up the next morning and went no no
no wait a minute this is a chance to be
25 years old again
with extraordinary extraordinary
resources and contacts and all these
things and like I just honestly I never
I had never imagined there would be
another get to start all over again and
the moment that that idea just came into
my my head I couldn't get out I couldn't
get away and it became more exciting to
me and so you know passing the baton to
the NBCUniversal people on DreamWorks
seemed like the most obvious must do
thing was better for my employees
because they would be part of this two
hundred billion dollar company I have
more job security and more resources and
these are people had been with me for a
long time and I felt a great sense of
obligation and loyalty to them I could
afford to take risks they might not you
know and all of these characters and
movies and IP that we had created to put
them in the hands of people that you
know could make them live forever if
they so choose to there couldn't be a
better place or a better organization to
to do that and for the shareholders it
was an extraordinary outcome a stock was
selling at $21 a share they bought it
for forty one dollars a share and so I
didn't I I couldn't put myself in
in the way of all of those three
outcomes which were better for for
everybody and then once that idea of
like okay you can start all over again I
would touch down
let's go minute so you are looking into
the future with excitement in your new
venture you are looking for the team to
pull around you and before we were
talking you described building a team
for our business as a casting process so
how are you casting for your new venture
right now
well again I you know one of the
recurring things for me over the years
is I've always had great mentors as I
talked about Barry Diller but Michael
Iseman it was a great mentor again we
were together for you know 18 and 1/2
those years it was a phenomenal
partnership and I learned so much from
him and so I've had a series of amazing
mentors over the years two people who
were mentors that went on to do
something different one Barry Diller and
he started this company called IAC about
25 years ago and the other was john
malone and liberty media and and i saw
in what they did something that excited
me because i am a builder and I'm an
operator I'm not an investor and I
believe that the most valuable thing is
human capital you you know to do to
build businesses to do things obviously
you need the cash to be able to do it
but the most valuable thing is human
capital and so in starting wonder Co I
wanted to put together a partnership of
people that if today you were going to
have a business either one that you were
starting or one that you already had
started and you wanted exceptional
resources to help you take that to some
you know great new plateau that within
wonder code we actually had everything
you would want in a C suite you have a
great strategist you have a great
marketing executive you have a general
counsel a CFO a CEO Oh a CEO like
everything that you would want
in a place like that we got some of and
so to have that as sort of the resource
because when I look at Barry Diller and
John Malone that's what they've done
they have found companies around ideas
and around entrepreneurs and then they
have put a ton of you know of people
capital into those enterprises and you
know Diller started IAC 25 years ago his
idea was the intersection of the
Internet and to be able to create
commercial consumer transactions on it
so everything from Expedia to I'm sure
no one in this room has ever actually
done anything that has anything to do
with match.com so you know he's just any
Barry's probably built literally 70 80
90 billion dollars worth of market cap I
mean it's like a quiet story not maybe
that will told but he's literally one of
the greatest entrepreneurs of our time
and I think right now today is exactly
another one of those moments and today
that intersection is technology and the
intersection of video and the
application of video against or
integrated with technology and how
transformative and imperative that is
going to be for what I think is the next
evolutionary if not revolutionary part
of of our world today and I'll try and
maybe translate that which is if you go
back maybe I don't know 1214 years ago
everybody was on a thing called an X
tell most people this remember too this
is you could send a text to somebody on
this little sort of page or device
somebody up here left it's probably over
40 and and then we went from that to a
to a flip phone and you had to actually
hit three times to get an R I know this
I'm speaking you know Swahili to you but
trust me and then I'm now getting into
territory here we went to a blackberry
and then from a blackberry to a
smartphone and so in the course of about
12 14 years everything or
text the application of text the
platform's around text so if you think
about communication collaboration
sharing search ecommerce and even
entertainment in a very short handful of
years text became ubiquitous the
enterprises built around text became
worth hundreds of billions if not
trillions of dollars and all of us
became expert at it
so like literally the ability of all of
us in any of us and everyone of us to
use text against those seven verticals
today is honestly as easy as putting one
foot in front of another so then about
five six years after that happened the
next thing that happened in that sort of
evolution was photography and so today
every single one of us is like a junior
Andy Leibovitz like we can all take
great photos no matter how inept we are
we can't help but take great photos and
so now think about in these last four or
five years the impact that photography
has had so we've moved and it's not it's
not displaced text it's added on text
why because a picture is that that is
better than a thousand words you've
heard that said before in it so now you
think about communication collaboration
you get it the application of
photography has been transformed and
once again many hundreds of billions of
dollars of market values but whether
it's you know Instagram or Pinterest and
we can go on and on okay so we're now in
the third cycle the sort of next third
evolution is the application of video
against each of those very specific
verticals and you're seeing what happens
when people come along and come up with
the application of putting these things
to these two things together so two
perfect examples of it are snapchat
right and in the world of communication
and sharing if you think about an
entertainment best example of its
Netflix you know Netflix is people
forget it was it they were you again I
don't have anybody remembers you used to
have a red envelope with a DVD in it
that's
only seven years ago you know now it's
it's it's streaming and a hundred
billion dollar market cap over the
intersection of video and technology so
for us today we have a team that we have
built that we think bridges that world
and there's a 12 of us nine of which
came our graduates at Stanford so thank
you all very much one of us is not a
graduate of Stanford he couldn't get in
here so you went to Harvard Business
School instead but he teaches here which
is sue JJ's what should stand up and
wave hello there cuz hopefully some of
you are being taught by him today come
on CJ show that t-shirt off stand up
stand up there we go
[Applause]
and so we we have a partnership that I
think is a great marriage and
collaboration between Northern
California and Southern California which
right now at this moment in time is
highly unique because we are different
cultures we actually speak different
languages but our codependency on one
another the integration of these two
worlds is is like literally these two
trains that are on their way at one
another and so for wonder Co we believe
we have the human capital to facilitate
that and to take advantage of it and to
be entrepreneurial around it an
incredible vision you seem to have
pretty boundless ambition for what's to
come and Meg Whitman is obviously gonna
lend a huge amount of experience well
it's a perfect example I've known Meg
for thirty years she's truly one of the
most extraordinary leaders and and and
just great great people she was on my
board at DreamWorks Animation we met
when I was at Disney we've started this
new business which is right now we as
our working title is called new TV but
it's an incredibly incredibly exciting
ambitious improbable likely impossible
dream that she and I now are sharing and
you know and it could only work by
putting our two worlds together and she
brings you know just a level of
knowledge and expertise she's you know
been at every whether it's what she did
it eBay or you know certainly at HP she
just has an incredible incredible set of
skills I don't and it is I I believe it
is one of those things where one plus
one is going to equal eleven I want to
thank you for everything you've shared
with us so far we're gonna pause for
Moto 'pn up to questions love it alright
my name is David I'm a second year here
and I'm inspired by your talk of the
move or the movement from the first a
second to third wave of video does
Wonder Co have any sort of ambitions on
saying what's after the third wave
well no cuz we got to get to the third
you know I think we're at the beginning
at the beginning of the third wave but I
actually think that you know when you
could just you know you just imagine
what the application is let me give you
just one place here which is you know
ecommerce so think about how much
ecommerce was changed from text to photo
right that the ability that you could
actually look at commerce on a on your
phone and see displayed for you you know
every single version of a Nike sneakers
you could imagine right okay now move to
video and video which is how the human
being actually functions sight and sound
is really the way in which we ingest
data in the most effective most
efficient way and we can put emotions
around those things so now think about
how all those versions of Nike will look
like in video so it it the and I say
that because we're in mister Nikes home
here we can thank him for this so but
the application of video for commerce is
going to be transformative as much as we
think we're you know had a you know I
would say we're in that sort of
evolutionary revolutionary moment from
retail into e-commerce I would I would
bet that we'll look at five seven years
from now won't look anything like it'll
be it just go to a whole nother level by
the application of video just that one
now we go to the other verticals and I
think it'll be as impactful I Mario yeah
we can hear you I'm an MBA one and my
question is what you learned from your
partnership with Spielberg and Geffen
how you've applied that into building
wonder Co and how you'll build your
future teams within the company um well
it was a it was Mena's amazing of a
partnership and and I think taught me
about what what the value of partnering
can be when Stephen and Dave and I came
together in 1994 if you went to Las
Vegas probably as many of you were going
to tonight you could place a bet on how
long would the three of them be able to
stay be in the same sandbox without
killing each other right and the odds
were you know a hundred to one that it
would blow up in a year or two but what
Stephen and David and I found in each
other is very specific expertise and as
partners we actually could rely on one
another so quite obviously in the world
of storytelling
you know Steven Spielberg arguably is
the greatest storyteller certainly among
greatest storytellers of our of our time
and so to defer to him as the sort of
final arbiter in that regard seem easy
and good to do and even for me who had
had you know amazing success before we
came to that partnership
I always felt deferential and even on
our animated movies you know I would
always bring Stephen in I mean right up
to the very end once a week he'd come
over and you know give me a warning and
I would engage him in every way in any
way I didn't always agree with him but I
always wanted to hear what he would have
to say David Geffen in the media space
probably the most successful
entrepreneur of our time he literally
made billions and billions and billions
of dollars from you know being you know
brilliant in the music business
brilliant and Broadway successful movie
producers it's just the guy has taste
and everything he did worked and so but
most of all a fantastic entrepreneur so
and I'm the Builder right so we had a
dreamer an entrepreneur
and a builder and those three things
were just incredible and and and
supportive of one another and so finding
that and being able to respect that in
one another I thought it was a bargain
because in 1994 as I said I had just
been fired Steven Spielberg had won the
Academy Award in the spring of 1994 for
Schindler's List and in June of 1994 he
put out the first Jurassic Park so in
our world he had won both the Academy
Award in the Bank of America Award
something rarely
somebody does those two at the same
David Geffen had actually just recently
sold his music company for the third or
fourth time for another billion dollars
to Universal and when I got fired I went
back to my office I left eisenerz office
and when I walked back to my I did not
know this at the time this is to give
you idea how kind of nasty you got so
I'm in this his office he just well I
don't think this is gonna work any
longer stating what would it at that
point was truly the obvious what I
didn't know is while I was in his office
he put a press release out saying that
he had fired me right so I get back to
my office and Lucia I walk into my
office and my assistant says to me
Steven Spielberg and Bob Zemeckis are on
the phone and they would not hang up
they've insisted on holding on until you
come back there and Jamaica together so
with the three of us had made a movie
called Roger Rabbit together and
actually had kind of a great bond and
you know relationship came out of out of
that movie and so I get on the phone and
then laugh and they go oh my god this is
fantastic it's just great and it's it's
funny and there I'm going really
explain to me how I'm what I'm missing
here because I'm not feeling any of this
guys and Bob Zemeckis I have they will
give him the credit for it Bob Zemeckis
says you know what Jeffrey you should
just start your own studio and I will
hung up the phone I went hmm no that's a
good idea
[Laughter]
literally that was the moment so we're
almost out of time to close I would ask
you to dig the reminiscence gene just
one more chorus onstage at the end the
day of the September 11th attacks the
entire country is paralyzed in shock and
mourning and you spring into action you
activate that sense of personal
responsibility and you put yourself at
the center can you describe that moment
for us and your leadership yeah it you
know it it was a moment for everybody
you know in this country if not around
the globe in which you you know that you
you know I think every single person was
not only feeling fear but also
helplessness and most of all what can I
do and I thought about that I felt like
I have to do something I'm not a fireman
I'm not a policeman I'm not a soldier
I'm an entertainer most of all above all
what I've tried to do my whole life is
actually bring laughter to people that's
been my mission and if you think about
the movies and you know the most joyful
rewarding thing for me is to stand in
the back of a theater and hear an
audience and laughter that's my joy and
it's literally the most beautiful thing
in the world to me is to hear laughter
and particularly the laughter of
children and I thought okay you know we
it would be great if we could have a
shared healing moment and and we my
community of entertainers actually could
do something and so
I had this idea of doing a telethon that
would be a tribute to America and the
strength of our country and was able to
do the thing I am I was able to do which
is to get everybody and anybody on the
telephone and talk them into doing
something that they never would ever
think of doing or what I would say think
of doing something they would not likely
do and so for the first time actually in
history every single television station
every cable station every radio every
everything for that two hours stopped
while the greatest and the best and you
know entertainers singers actors spoke
from the heart
and and and I I just for me when I think
of all of the wonderful things that I
have been able to do and had in my
career honestly nothing even comes
remotely close to that moment and that
time in which I felt you know it was it
was the ultimate unifying shared moment
and just for a second I felt maybe there
was at this tragic tragic time happiness
thank you so much for the gifts that
you've given us over an incredible
career and today in this auditorium we
are so blessed
[Applause]